wow
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody sorry
we're a little bit late this evening I
had a little bit of a makeup disaster as
I said on YouTube
uh I was stupidly trying to put my fake
lashes on and the glue ran in my eye
and then it caused both of my eyes to
tear up and then all of my eye makeup
ran off so I had to start all over again
yeah we're going out tonight when the
show's over Jenny got her [__]
clothing shipmented man it's [__] off
the chain
um
and she's got something on right now man
only I only I can see it I can
appreciate it she looks like somebody's
Gothic big boob secretary man big old
[__] Double H cups little bitty waist
big booty and she's show the stockings
yeah
oh come on put your foot up there
she's got a little yeah
nice and just her like she's been in
training and working out and her [__]
legs are looking all juicy and [__] she
just looks really good
that Sheen app
get kicked out that's pretty awesome for
130 bucks I spent oh yeah I've 130 that
included shipping it took a week to get
here which wasn't bad because yeah I
ordered them actually less than a week
because I ordered them last Saturday or
Sunday and it came today and I got for
130 and that included shipping I got six
six pillar dresses six dresses they're
nice they're not that's one of them yeah
two wigs two wigs they're cool too good
too uh three or four pairs of stockings
two pairs of gloves yeah real cool
gloves um several necklaces two or three
pairs of earrings yeah uh what the [__]
else did I get I got some other yeah
he's a set of three yeah like I said
like some underwear like with skulls and
[__] on them like I think it was three
or four pairs yeah yeah but it was just
like a whole and every single one of the
dresses looks perfect yeah and they're
like high quality I was thinking I I was
like 11 bucks a dress right you know
because I was thinking I was skeptical
because I was like is this gonna be like
a wish situation where it's like it
looks super awesome on the thing it's
like oh my God it's only 20 and then you
get it and it's like this [__] rag
that doesn't look anything like the
picture
um so I was kind of afraid because all
these dresses were like yeah like eleven
dollars yeah right they're thick stretch
materials but yeah they're all really
nice stand up and show it show them that
I mean this one that was like an 11 yeah
this was 11. look at those God damn Jen
you're a huge back up a little bit look
at your boobs back up so you can see
the whole dress over here
's what this stockings and everything
yeah there you go go ahead and turn
around Jim
yeah
she looks good yeah I got some cool I
got some cool [__] man yeah I got every
one of the dresses with cute one of them
had a damn print of a girl with a
machine gun it's black and it has a a
girl with a machine gun and uh Flames
behind her and it had it just looks
really good too and I think that was
only like a an eight or eight dollar
dress I think
I think it was eight dollars yeah it
looks it looks [__] it's like one of
the best dresses but they were all good
another one is black one like this with
a red liner
it's like a like a red built-in slip in
it yeah it's really good and then a
couple of fairy core dresses that look
really good they're like something
[__] uh Courtney Love with a war yeah
one was like kind of like a dark antique
green with like black butterflies on it
yeah like so it looks very it looks like
all antique and like Cabinet of
Curiosities reddish purple with a bunch
of yeah and then the other one's kind of
like a like a dark Dusty red yeah but
yeah those are really nice like the cuts
of them they're it's kind of it looks a
little bit like 90s throwback
um the cuts of them but there's you know
I'm not mad about that yeah actually the
one dress that that I got that had like
the red liner inside it I had a dress
very similar to that back in the 90s
matter of fact but it had it was hot
pink like with black over it and had
like little Egyptian like things on it
they're saying welcome welcome to flash
bulbs that was murder horns yeah okay
because murder Hornet was a member
before yeah what did he send what do you
send is there is there it just says
welcome to okay all right I got you I
thought that was a money thing it was
just a member talking that's a new
feature I haven't seen that
no it's not it's not new okay yeah we've
had that and he was a member before but
I think like it messed up yeah and then
he came back again
look at this like Zach is cracking me up
uh or you're drunk shopping on Amazon
yeah we've all been there
um and get a super cheap chair only to
realize it's a doll chair
a mistake you only make two or three
times
yeah I mean I've had that happen
not to me personally but I knew somebody
that had that were like oh my God look
at this love seat or whatever and it's
like really reasonable and then they got
it and it was like child size you know
like it was for like a like a toddler so
it wasn't like a normal size but you
couldn't tell that from the picture
because they didn't have anything in the
picture that would like give you the
relative size of it so yeah you get it
and it's just like it's baby size and I
was just like well that's that's no good
is it but yeah so I was like I was
really happy with uh everything like
everything was like really high uh
quality so it will be shopping there
again yeah you also got that law there
she had a long dress to Slit all the way
up the sides and it turns into fish nets
and it just got it has cups it doesn't
have the Mandarin collar like the other
one it looks good yeah it looks really
kind of buckle things yeah straps with
buckles go across crash your hips or
whatever yeah it looks good on her
but yeah they got some uh good [__] and
it's all like reasonably priced so yeah
but and I think these I think some of
the stuff that we bought
is available in other colors so we can
go back and buy that again in other
colors yeah
I mean it might be in red too yeah which
uh yeah that'd be a nice thing it's in
red and white
or and gray there was another dress like
this that was really cool
um it was kind of this a similar cut but
it had like silver buttons that went
down farther and it was just like
slightly different and I really really
liked that one as well but it's like
when I went back in there to get it
because it said they only had one left
so I'm assuming when I by the time I
went to the cart I think that that she
and F has everything it has got stuff
for men the men's selection I don't
really like it that much but they had to
have a whole military selection or they
had boots like military style boots I've
never recognized any of those Brands but
they're like only 40 or 50 bucks for
what looks like a hundred dollar pair of
boots I'm tempted
to buy some but boots are risky man
sometimes boots look great you wear them
for seven months so they fall apart you
know and Military shit's gonna be on
point
but hey man the expensive [__] that we
buy here has been actually made in China
if you were to follow how it was made
just got to get good good quality
Chinese [__]
curly said where did you order the
clothes from uh it's an app
s-h-e-i-i-n yeah s s h e i n it's an app
get that app
it seems like it's pretty much mostly
clothing and accessories right yeah I
don't know if they have other shows uh
they do have other stuff oh I don't
think they actually have a camping stuff
they have a bunch of [__] really it's
like a department store it has
everything because I was just looking at
clothes they surprisingly have real
[__] hip women's clothes subculture
stuff got fairy core stuff Golf Stuff
punk rock stuff metal stuff they have a
lot of good a lot of good accessories
for women
like I said the men's selection's not so
good it's like [__] that Chinese guys
would wear if you ask me the uh you know
[__] Wiggles the too many skinny
jeans and just [__] you know what I mean
and it's
it's not something that American guys
would wear but they had military stuff
and then they got like Normie stuff you
know just like if you're looking for
[__] you know yeah if you want Normie
stuff yeah if you you know [__] cargo
pants you know and
shirts and they have all that suits they
have all that
dress shoes and [__] work clothes yeah
subjective perspective Collective says
my wife buys a ton from there well I'm
gonna start doing that too because this
was like um you know this was a test
because it's we'd saw this stuff on
there and I was like man there's a lot
of cool [__] on here I said I'm gonna
get a bunch of [__] if it all turns out
good then maybe like once a month or
every couple months
I can buy yeah well [__] yeah I mean if
you can say spend a hundred dollars and
get like [__] four or five dresses
more six more yeah because I got six and
that's six and that was like less
because like I said I got a bunch of
other stuff yeah you had the skirt and
the little oh yeah yeah I forgot about
that so so that was another outfit like
yeah I had like a little top with skull
skulls all over and a little short skirt
with like little uh bonded [__] on it
had it been nothing but
dresses about that level and you spent
130 you would have had about seven of
them yeah probably so yeah I can't even
remember yeah yeah I got I got so many
dresses yeah and I totally forgot about
the other because I knew there was more
stuff and I was just like yeah I got
another top and another yeah that looked
good too
it all like I said I was happy because
that was the one thing I was worried
about I was like man I would hate to
like spend this money and then I get it
and nothing fits right and then
everything fit exactly right and the
women's stuff is kind of stretchy which
always helps so
it's it's forgiving with the sizes uh it
does it doesn't have to be perfect
like she's wearing that one I think that
was a large she could probably wear a
medium too it'd probably look also look
good
yeah because it says yeah but like I
said I always like buy a large just in
case because I've had a pro I've had
problems where
you know I bought something that was a
medium and it fit everywhere except it
wouldn't fit over my chest yeah and so I
can't wear it you know what I mean which
kind of sucks so now I just buy a large
just because because I'm like I don't I
don't want to get the whole thing and
have it fit everywhere except over by
over by chest area yeah okay update on
um
uh [__] our side project with only
fans and all that
oh man we've submitted
tried to Jenny got one channel going for
herself we I don't think it's verified
she thinks it is but I don't think well
no I didn't say that I just said I
hadn't finished all the banking
information because I hadn't had time to
yeah yeah that doesn't verify it though
they're just no I know but I'm just
saying that I hadn't fit I hadn't
finished the process as well I've been
trying for like two or three days just
can't get the verification there's
always something wrong with the photo
always something wrong with a [__]
piece of paperwork always something
wrong with the photograph of the ID they
just complained constantly I was
starting to take the [__] personally I
closed the counter I had I said [__]
them I'm not gonna deal with them so I
went over there and started doing the
fans lead which is another one it's
similar because I've because I was
reading how many other people were
having a problem getting the
verification done
and I thought that was just I thought it
was just maybe person personal because
of our age demographics or some
so I called my friend in a business he's
in he's in the [__] hardcore foreign
business Bill and he's local here and I
was I told him and he says oh no welcome
to the business he says get back in
there because it [__] takes sometimes
weeks to get that [__] right he says if
he says if you're taking pictures of
that of those IDs he says you really
ought to take that somewhere and have
them scanned well I can scan I can scan
him here and I was like uh okay scan
them and then put them in a JPEG and
just keep giving the same jpeg over and
over again every time they [__] knock
you down for something and eventually
they're like well
you could have everything right and they
would say you don't have a Twitter they
do [__] like that so then you got to go
get a Twitter they they try to knock
people out that they are that they don't
think are committed or won't make money
at it
so it's a hurdle you gotta
go oh when you hear all these people
talking about well you could just quit
your job babe [__] go on only fans
like you can just do that
no no they curate the [__] out they're
curious
getting on that one because everybody's
trying to get on it
is uh like going to work for a
television Studio
they're going to be like
nah you're just gonna be a waste of
[__] space
that shit's not gonna sell so but
[__] bill was like oh no you guys
will sell there just [__] keep going
keep going yeah well I still have my
account open I just haven't finished it
yet because I haven't had time but I'm
gonna set it up over the weekend and I'm
gonna set up like a Twitter account for
uh for 13km or whatever we're calling it
yeah and um maybe there's a bunch of
legal [__] that's a problem
making a joint account is they don't
like that they don't really yeah so
we're having so we're trying to figure
out
if we're I mean if if we just set up a a
an account under one of our names and
one of our faces and then if you post
content with you and somebody else like
we were gonna do you have to have
released then you have to have a release
form that basically says hey this person
who owns this account is allowed to put
up videos with this person in it yeah
for however long each video you got to
print out a consent form you got to go
through the whole verification process
again and [__] show pictures and
pictures of the ID pictures of the
pictures of yourself
yeah so it's not like you're just
sitting there all day [__] loading
pictures man the the law is [__]
stringent when it comes to this and only
fans can't get in any trouble they don't
want to be in any trouble so everything
has to be [__] perfect well they
don't like joint account
they just don't like it because if it's
a couple and the couple break up
lawsuits could happen because she can go
hey he's got control of the count and
that's all my photos and he's making all
the money off of everything where's my
half that and I'm sure that's happened
in the past and they're just like yeah
we don't want to deal with it so what
they like to do is that each account is
an individual person if they're both
individually verified they can tag each
other in them in the material
and you can see it that way because
they're already verified they don't have
to go through the [__] individual
which is probably what we'll end up
probably the best way to do it and what
they can do is I can have an account she
could have an account but we could all
post it on her account
my account would basically be dead
I would just the only thing is that
every photo would have every photo or
video would have a tag if I'm in it
saying it's this user is co-starring
yeah but you go over to that user you
follow it's just going to be picture
Amigo you know whatever
it's not an actor it's not an active
Channel it doesn't have its own feed
because you don't want to compete
against your your feeds you don't want
to compete you know what I mean well it
wouldn't matter because I mean you could
just post this the money always going to
the same place anyway right that's what
I mean I mean you could just post the
same [__] on your thing right as I post
on my thing we just posted the same
thing in this business the females are
the draw they're the bait all right guys
don't really generate much money unless
it's gay content
and even they have problems
so if you have a situation where you
have an account
and it's like a joint account but then
they look at the account and it's his
bank account but she's the one that's
actually pulling the customers they're
like Ah that's almost like pimping they
don't like how that looks right they're
like why isn't she getting the money so
really it would make more sense if it
was going into your bank account they
would probably approve that easier
uh that way you have control of that
account and it's you have control of
that account it's under your name and
it's linked to your bank account
which because in this in this particular
industry we're talking about the dudes
are just stunt [__] man they're they're
[__] they're they're Hired Hands
they're extras
that's not who's what's drawn a male
customer
because women don't buy this
person the dudes don't care if I'm in it
or not they're not there for me
you know what I mean so it's just the
reality of that particular business
the guy could help there are some male
porn stars I just thought were great
they were [__] funny you know
um but you don't see videos out with
that dude
right big difference
this is marketing yeah I mean it's
where's the money you know
Sarah D says what a nightmare at the
same time maybe it's to protect people
from getting trafficked or something
yeah yeah I guess they just don't want
the appearance like I said they probably
don't want the legal hassle you can go
into a court of law and make all kinds
of [__] appear certain ways even if
that's not the way it was
uh but they don't want people fighting
over content yeah if there's more like a
couple gets divorced and then they're
fighting over that content they're both
in it so
there has to be a clear legal chain of
custody and ownership
so it's a lot more complicated than
people think you just can't [__] make
these [__] videos until I can put
them up
you're making a controlled item and the
platforms that are delivering it are
paranoid because they've been burned
yeah yeah
well and also it's kind of like right
for exploitation like somebody said it's
like yeah people could put up some [__]
that like was absolutely not consensual
so I'm sure they're really trying to be
as careful
gorilla gorilla that's where you're
basically strong arm and some girl
to do
prostitution
when she doesn't do it then you know he
cuts he cuts off her power or you know
he's kind of she lives with him you know
I mean it's basically an abusive
boyfriend that's forcing the girlfriend
to go out and [__]
hook herself she doesn't want to do it
but she doesn't really have a choice
it's called gorilla Pippin yeah
yeah of course that's illegal
and of course
girls in that situation evidently don't
last long you know bad bad their
psychology gets [__] up but so I can
see how if you
you know go on only fans like I did like
as a
you know as a woman's account yeah
that's obviously me and it's like you
know take my picture with my ID and all
that kind of crap then they'll probably
have approve me a lot quicker than they
would to me because it's more normal
yeah
for them and that industry it's a lot
more normal
she's like oh yeah she'll make money
they'll just let her in
she can work whoever she chooses just as
long as she does consent form yeah well
that's all they care about and if we
have to do it that way we'll do it that
way
so I'm basically an employee in her show
which really that's what it is I was
trying to explain it to her there before
I said she wants we got to do a showing
things it's really gonna be your show
because they're not gonna be there for
me
well I know that but it's like that's
not what I meant though it's like I know
that but it's like I still
want to do this [__] together because
it's like that's what was the fun of it
for me I don't really yeah I'll work
with you of course I don't just want to
be hanging out there by myself it's been
a lot of fun we've shot a bunch of stuff
which is worrying me because when you
fill out the consent forms a lot of it
has to do with what dates dates that
things were shot on
no the consent form is just saying like
basically how long are you giving this
person the account holder the rights to
own your content okay that's what it's
asking you okay
all right because I was always because I
think that video
material if you have the right software
you can go and see inside the data what
the date was when it was filmed yeah
and I didn't know if some of those forms
want to know on what day that was filmed
now it just it just asked you basically
how long are you giving this person the
rights to this video content okay so I
may feel a little bit better over that
yeah that's all it was asking because
bill was like well wait a minute don't
you don't you need don't shouldn't you
be filling out the forms now and I said
well we don't have a place to release it
you know yeah but the dates
they're going to want to know when that
was [__] was shot
it was like really he goes yeah it's
time stamped
that's what he said but the thing is is
that he said it's not uniform every
platform was different yeah that's what
I'm saying so it's like you always have
to go in each one yeah that's why we've
kind of been trying out like he'll go
and make an account somewhere and just
kind of like look around in there to see
how I'm trying to use it yeah and try to
work you know yeah see what it's like
like from the users yeah they want to
know the security yeah I was impressed
with stream mate you just can't jump in
they seemed like the best one yeah
that's why we kind of just they want to
work with streammate
because you can't go in there and [__]
around you'll just immediately get
booted which that's the plus you're
being watched they're invisible monitors
in there yeah for Content creators
that's much better yeah like but
customers might not like it but because
they might think it's Draconian or
whatever but it's much better for the
people making yeah the idea is that they
don't want any new accounts going in
there they don't know who this
[__] is yet of course you have
to give your
in order to interact with a streamer and
stream mate
you have to have a full activated
account which means that you've given
them your credit card information right
that way you can tip you know and pay
for things
so that hurdle right there eliminates a
lot of trouble a troll is not going to
[__] go through the problem give this
credit card information when he gets
[__] booted [__] uh 15 minutes
later yeah because you can get [__]
thrown out of thrown out of a room and
eventually you can get thrown off the
platform if you just run around which
like I said that's you basically when
it's that kind of thing like I kind of
feel like yeah the performers
safety and you know well-being should be
the top priority really well what you do
you know what what they're worried about
is you know there's some girls she's
putting on her show dudes painted her
way to the show and he starts insulting
her right and she sees it you know what
I mean [__] and it ruins a show for
everybody [__] get out of here
you know what I mean yeah that's what I
mean and it's like yeah I always want to
like what the [__] is the psychology of
like people that do that oh I don't know
they just like to shoot I didn't see any
of it no I'm just saying that it does
happen yeah I didn't see any of it when
I was in there
um everybody was respectful I didn't see
anybody being rude so like I said maybe
they just because they'll throw you out
of there yeah and there's certain things
they can't talk about you can't I was
trying to talk to some of the performers
because when they're in between acts you
can interact with them all right I was
asking a question there's a girl from
Germany
and I and I started to ask I said yeah
we're thinking about doing this from
another platform there's rules here and
I didn't know what the [__] she was
talking about they can't even talk about
other platforms
oh okay yeah I didn't know about that
makes sense yeah another another guy in
the in in in in the in the in the Stream
in the [__] chat sections because
they can't talk about other planets
right so which that's pretty standard
it's almost kind of like a
yeah like like if you work somewhere
you're not allowed to work yeah they're
like exactly the problem is is that you
cannot promote our YouTube channel in
other words 13 o'clock right from stream
me yeah
and uh somebody said well you can do the
[__] clandestinely
around it probably well yeah and then
you know no shirts and [__] like that
you know but yeah
but you just can't plug other channels
right but like you said you could do
something sneaky like put some ads in
the background or something yeah they
put ads in the background
uh Sarah says what you sipping on over
there by the way oh man this is two
different things it's mine is vodka with
Publix brand fruit punch yeah which is
like a buck what was it a buck a buck
tan a buck 10. for a two liter that
shit's good man mixes with vodka good
too we here in Florida we got Publix
that we got Publix and Win Dixie
they're both pretty good but Publix got
wind Dixie beat
Publix has the best ice cream it's
almost as good as Bluebell all right
they're they're their store brand
because they have their own Creamery and
then they're sodas they're two liters
they're just as good as any other
soda if not better and they got pretty
good diet drinks but one of the things I
found
is that they have one called fruit punch
it's just red
red flavor it's red flavor and what red
flavor is in this particular
one is it's Hawaiian Punch but it's
slightly carbonated yeah so it's [__]
good yeah and it's a great mixer it is
yeah it mixes with vodka but it also
mixes with silver tequila and that's
what I got I got you got Silver Tequila
yeah I got [__]
the [__] red punch
with a little bit of real guava juice in
it and so and Sam's Silver Tequila in it
and I'm a Sam's Club member too Sam's
has got great [__] booze look at the
name brand they're super cheap yeah and
they're they're the Sam's brand their
generic brand the Vodka that they have
is identical to [__] Gray Goose so
you can get a huge [__] fifth of that
[__] for like 10 bucks
and then they only have one tequila and
it comes in a big old pretty decanter
and it's a silver tequila with a cork on
it
and it's indistinguishable from [__]
uh Milagro silver
and you know I like tequila as
if you were to say which one you want
you want the salves or Milagro I go give
it a Sams yeah that's good I can't tell
them apart
yeah and that uh it's only like uh
I think it's 20 bucks
yeah I think that's how much it was and
you know if that was Milagro it'd be
more like 40.
well yeah that's the thing when I get
vodka because sometimes you know because
Sam's is kind of far Sarah said um I do
like Silver Tequila Sam's is like Costco
yeah it's essentially the same thing
yeah it's like it's like a warehouse
type thing
Sarah yeah yeah
um but yeah so normally if we don't
haven't gone to Sam's because we only
make a Sam's run probably like in two
months maybe something like that because
it's far you know what I mean so if you
go there you're gonna spend like 600 in
stockings
buying meat mostly yeah like for the
freezer yeah
um so normally I would just go to the
liquor store that's just right down the
street like by the Publix and I usually
get Sky Vodka and that for the same size
bottle is
24.99 yeah and you can get the same size
bottle that tastes pretty much exactly
the same from Sam's for I think is 13.99
yeah I've always equated the Sam's vodka
with more like uh Gray Goose or Skye I
think more like Gray Goose but the uh
here's the thing you don't have to be a
member though
of Sam's to buy that not for the liquor
store not for the liquor because the
liquor store is outside the main store
and they don't check you you can just go
in there and get it if you want good if
you like to keep Silver Tequila
you know and you like Milagro and you
don't want to pay the Milagro price go
in there and get that Sam's tequila I'm
plugging it
Sam's to kill this [__] good and even
the bot even the Decatur is pretty it's
kind of tear drop shaped flat
the rum is good too yeah whiskey is not
good that is that's the only Sam's
alcohol that I bought because we bought
I think I bought the Gin there too yeah
it was good their Scotch whiskey is no
good but the whiskey sucks but other
than that everything else is good
the the rum the regular silver rum and
the spice rum is great it's like 15
bucks per fifth
and it's good it's about like Captain
Morgan
yeah they got the spiced and they got
silver
raw they're good they're they're cheap
too I think they're about 12 13 bucks 14
bucks yeah I haven't bought any room
there in a while yeah
uh yeah it makes you miss some rum
yeah I don't remember it was probably it
was several months ago we bought rum for
the last time but usually I just get
vodka because that goes with everything
you know spiced rum and hot apple cider
in the winter
can't [__] beat it man I can't wait
till it's like Auto time again so we can
have that kind of stuff yeah you can
just get loaded
hot apple cider in a mug
Spike with [__]
Spiced Rum yummy
yeah it gives you good and you like run
with like with the eggnog yeah like rub
an eggnog at Christmas time yeah not
spiced eggnog though it clashes you just
want regular silver rum eggnog ice
[__] right
yeah Sarah said uh Costco brand vodka
tequila Etc is always comparable to
high-end Brands I find okay yeah we
don't have one around here there is one
but I can't remember where it's at it's
probably good Costco Costco and Sam's
are competitors yeah they are yeah
because it's essentially the same thing
so they got a stick they gotta keep up
you know
those distilleries are all coming from
the same place the distilleries make
[__] booze for a lot of different
companies you don't know but a lot of
that [__] comes from the same The
Distillery
yeah Camp guy says no liquor in grocery
stores Sam's or Costco in Georgia or
Tennessee or Alabama yeah that's right
they have those weird [__] laws weird
Dove yeah dry loss yeah it's like here
they have liquor well they have beer and
wine in grocery stores obviously but a
lot of grocery stores will have a liquor
store but it's next to it that's what
that's how we do it here so it's like so
Publix now the Publix we have down there
a lot of publics do have a liquor store
though it's outside like next to it the
one we have down here that's a different
liquor store it's just like a
mom-and-pop liquor store uh Walmart does
that too like the Walmart by my work
which is in Daytona
uh you know there's a Walmart and then
you go outside and there's like a liquor
store next to it it's like Walmart
liquors so that's it's which is dumb
it's like the law says they can't sell
it technically in the grocery store
itself so they're just like well [__]
you we're just gonna open a liquor store
right next to the grocery store yeah
Camp guys talking yeah it's the same way
here in Florida yeah you can't sell
liquor in a grocery store
but but you can sell it out of a liquor
store attached to a grocery store yeah
because Publix has a liquor store it's
just not inside the store and it's next
to it so does uh
so does a Walmart
you got the Walmart and then right next
to the Walmart
not even 25 yards is the concrete wall a
concrete building that is a liquor store
owned by Walmart they're not connected
not physically connected
and actually they had good [__] in there
this is a pretty big liquor store yeah
they didn't have I didn't notice any
Walmart brands they were just regular
Brands yeah they just had regular yeah
and and the prices were good
Zach said I noticed when I was in
Louisiana last year I couldn't get on
certain porn sites any idea why that is
yeah they can't block any of that that's
weird though thank you but there well
the weird thing about it is that like a
lot of states in the South they have
like weird laws too about like sex toys
and [__] like yeah they're probably
still like that like you can't send
dildos through the mail and yeah like so
you can't order dildos like to order to
certain States I think Alabama was like
that it's probably not like that anymore
I don't know it was just well it was a
few years ago because well no because
that's when I was remember when I was
selling sex toys on Amazon okay yeah and
they were like real like they couldn't
ship to Alabama kind of stuff because
they were [__] lost weird yeah yeah
in Mississippi that went county by
county
um so it wasn't a state law it was a
county law
and it could be that
in some of those States like Alabama was
talking about so many counties are like
that that it's just too much of a legal
risk to send anything to that state
right but remember in Mississippi when I
was a teenager
at least in the county I was in which
have been Jones
um there was no porn
all right it was not legal to sell in
public I think you could possess it but
you couldn't sell it in public and what
they did was the church groups they
didn't want their kids going into
you know they call them dime stores in
Mississippi which is like a corner store
a small grocery store yeah we call them
that territory not yeah okay well you
see that's like old-time running and
seeing a rack damn porn
they didn't want their kids seeing that
gay porn rack so they didn't make any
kind of special laws where like you know
hey it's got to be covered up or it's
got to be they just said no you can't do
it you can't sell it in public because
their the thinking was is that it would
be up on a rack somewhere in kids to see
it so that was the thinking but they
they came up with that [__]
long time ago probably 60s
the people that made those laws up or
gone they're dead yeah
and you know they had some nasty ass
porn in their house too because why are
they so [__] worried about who knows
everyone else looking at porn what they
usually did like when I went in
convenience stores as a kid was that
they would put all the porn behind the
counter and it would be up on the rack
but they had like plastic over it that
had like you know like black bars so you
couldn't see the covers yeah you could
just see the name of the so it's like
hey it's big jugs but you couldn't see
like the [__] you know what I mean
that's what they did what happened where
I was kind of growing up in Mississippi
it was probably legal to rent
VHS porn
but I never saw any of it for sale for
rent and it was probably just be and it
was because it was so outside
Mississippi culture when I was hanging
out down there that they just the the
store owners were like I would never do
that they're just not like that they
didn't they didn't like that [__] at all
um it wasn't within their frame of
reference
and they also um the a lot of the
counties were were dry which means you
couldn't sell hard liquor
you could sell booze like we're not blue
uh wine and beer but you couldn't sell
hard liquor
now other counties you could so the you
could always find bars you'd find bars a
lot of times on the borders between a
wet county and a dry cat they say you
find bars there and the thinking was
old-fashioned thinking
booze in the South hard liquor in the
South was like crack
you had Bootleggers that made it and
they were gangsters and they were
[__] running Rob and shooting people
and getting into chases with the cops so
the southern thinking the old-fashioned
Southern thinking of the time was just a
ban it okay like Banning drugs they just
considered it to be that way and the
churches backed them up with it but like
I said it was just piecemeal it wasn't
every County depending on the
demographics of the county
and then you had whole generations of
people growing up especially
you know women there was women mostly
there were tea totalers oh no you know
and especially if they went a lot of
them went to church
and they didn't know they didn't know
anything about the outside world really
they're kind of suburban they're
Suburban country they think they're
above the [__] working class country
people
who were sinful and in civilized society
you don't have liquor it's like Islam
you're based very much like Islam
and uh
there's a [__] kind of an outsider I
know the Southern Culture [__] super
well the thinking I was in the deep
south of Mississippi it's where I was
kind of spent all of my Summers as my
youth visited my dad there
Outsiders [__] always especially now
they say well it's these [__] racist
[__] religious
poor males of guy that are dominating
all these people no it was a lot of
times the women it was church going
women that were more like middle class
trying to get the poor people to shape
up
Southern men drank
they wanted to drink but they were
getting shamed into going along with
this [__]
there were also poon hounds all right
they [__] anything that moved
you know what I mean sorry you sounded
like Frank Booth there oh [__] anything
yeah yeah
the thinking of The Outsiders is that
Southerners Were Somehow like prudish no
no especially in the working class they
were wild they were almost poly all
right A lot of them had a wife and some
girlfriends you know they were they were
just like that
and um
it was as far Stranger Than Fiction you
know you'd have guys back in the 60s
that were married
to some high school sweetheart and he's
in the clan maybe which they weren't
even respected back in the 60s and he's
got two black girlfriends and a bunch of
you know mixed kids it doesn't make any
[__] sense to an outsider but that's
the way they were you know well people
don't make it yes yeah because they're
not logical no they're not
I wish I have a hard time with because
I'm a very logical person but you know
what I mean
but I get it I get it yeah well the
thing about well I think the thing about
that all of those kind of like uh you
know those laws like that like those
Busy Body old ladies that were like
trying old ladies yeah and all of that
that was always just for show yeah they
weren't like that those old ladies
weren't like that that's what I'm saying
they were probably like the biggest
freaks ever yeah yeah it's always the
biggest freaks that are kind of like
yeah trying to like make themselves look
like they're all [__] in the South
that I was growing up in in the 70s and
[__]
the Working Class People were very
pragmatic and realistic and almost kind
of hedonistic
um the uh they partied a lot
it was a very open sexuality uh there
were a lot of promiscuity from an early
age
a lot of the girls were pregnant you
know by 20 easily
and
sometimes by several different guys you
know uh and this [__] started in their
teens
you know
it wasn't prudish at all
all the Busy Body stuff that we were
just talking about that was a reaction
to reality the southern was
The South was always Wild
it was wild and permissive because it
was Anarchy it was
kind of Lawless
you could get what you could do anything
you wanted really there's weren't any
cops
everything was held together by
Traditions traditions and culture they
were good people these are not bad
people none of them were bad really
um just uh
like she said people trying to be
do-gooders trying to make other people
behave
and then you look into that [__] and
she's the biggest [__] and [__] in
church you know what I mean she but the
reason why she tried to get everybody to
behave is because she's misbehaving she
can't control her own behavior so she's
trying to [__] control everybody
else's Behavior well sometimes too cut
them all out and people go along with it
okay we'll vote for this you know what I
mean and it's all just
and then as soon as the soonest Sunday's
over those people are go back to [__]
around and doing all the [__] they were
doing is fake sometimes people that are
like really shitty people they think
that everyone else is as shitty as they
are
and so they're like well if I you know
if everyone else was in the same stage
well I would do this terrible thing so
everyone Ergo like everyone else would
do it too but that's not the case I'm
like no you're just a [__] you're just a
shitty person and the South was
religious but only on the surface
mostly on Sunday and in public
in reality no they weren't they didn't
they were Partiers
and and like I said they were hedonistic
I had a lot of fun there but you know
you I could pick through what was
[__] and what wasn't [__]
because there's always about it's like
Japan you know there's a public face
the south is like that there's a public
face
and being a Believer is part of the
public face they didn't believe it
though they just definitely didn't live
it most of them
Mr 88 said the most immoral people out
there the Christian athlete prayer folk
in high school were the same ones that
went down on the entire football team
yeah yeah and he's from Oklahoma he said
Oklahoma often leads the U.S in teen
pregnancy yep yeah
actually I knew I knew several girls
that were pregnant in high school
actually I knew one girl that was
pregnant in junior high school well um
there's an element of kink
if if you're not supposed to do it well
then it's more kinky so they do it
and it's like that everywhere
yeah
what is forbidden now starts becoming
[__] enticing
but I had fun growing up in the South
like but I wouldn't want to live there
full time like I said it was mostly
during the Summers
I had to go back to either California or
Brazil
with my mom
when I was a kid because my parents
divorced
and then I went back to the south after
the uh before the service for a few
years and then after I went back and I
lived here eventually you know it was in
Louisiana Mississippi and now Florida
and in general I had fun
out of all the places in the South that
I've lived in I'd take Florida
uh Louisiana is a [__]
it's fun but it's just man trouble
Mississippi too quiet for me not enough
nightclubs
although the Mississippi Gulf Coast is
evidently well developed now you can
[__] have a lot of fun there because
I lived there too past Christiane
they're my first wife for a couple years
year and a half and then we got divorced
and then uh but I liked I liked the
Bay St Louis past Christian Biloxi area
fun
Sarah D said or they did butt stuff so
they could technically keep their
virginity yeah Garfunkel and Oates did a
whole song about that called the
loophole yeah
it's very funny like check it out yeah
Mr 88 said I'm not from Oklahoma yeah
Steve sorry about that I didn't mean to
say they were from Oklahoma uh I am from
Los Angeles but moved to Oklahoma during
my junior year of high school okay yeah
there we go so you like me you've been
in both worlds
and I also lived up Michigan too
yeah and Boston you lived everywhere
yeah
yes I've been in you know I've had some
people well you've only you've never
been up here so who the [__] you talking
about man I'm [__] six years I'm in
Boston
you know and then when I was in Boston I
go to New York City too
which I actually preferred in in the 90s
this was after I came out of the army I
preferred New York City to Boston even
though I lived in Boston I liked the
people better they were New Yorkers are
tougher
uh easier to talk to get along with they
weren't snotty I liked them
um
bostonians or
mostly not from Boston and they think
very highly of themselves
now the people that were born and raised
in Boston
North End that area
no there
a lot a lot more down to earth you know
but anybody having to do with the
university system
and people in the clubs people see the
golf clubs nah but they weren't from
there they all migrated to there you
know what I mean
Sarah's laughing at the loophole yeah if
you've never heard that song actually
Garfunkel and Oates are really really
funny like the loophole is probably one
of their funniest songs but for some
reason like the funniest song to me is
one that's called pregnant women are
smug like that that would always fix you
but they're like they're super [__]
hilarious they're lyrics Tyler says he
lives in Mississippi Missouri it's
[__] boring as hell flat yeah yeah
there are some places there's just
nothing to do
yeah yeah I'd probably drink myself to
death if I live there at least in
Mississippi was there was stuff to do
especially if you were young
like and I mean real young like not old
enough to go to a club
if you were a kid you could [__] have
a lot of fun there
um but you kind of outgrow it it's a
good place to maybe retire now
especially you know like in the deeper
part of the South
but the coast is [__] great it's it's
rolling it's like Atlantic City probably
better than Atlantic City actually
kind of like something more like out of
Florida
American Military 100 random question if
an Infamous serial killer like Carla
Homolka oh I just listened to Simon
whistler's show about uh Paul Bernardo
and Carla Hamilton I'm on my way home
from work yesterday uh if she was
murdered by a vigilante should her
killer face criminal charges
hmm only if he's in custody they're
going to do that that's what the system
is going to do I don't see a lot of
people were pissed because she got let
out basically they only gave her [__]
what was it eight years or 12 years I
can't remember they gave her like some
[__] sentence even though they found
out like they knew that she was totally
in on the [__] too and like a lot of it
was her idea I don't know who it is um
we did a show about them like a long
time it was one of the couples the
Barbie and Ken Killers oh okay yeah and
like I said I'm kind of familiar with
the details of it more than I would have
been because I was listening somebody
told me on Wednesday night's show they
said oh Simon Whistler
um casual criminalist he just put up
like a two-hour show about them so I
actually listened to it yesterday so I'm
like pretty well caught up with the
thing yeah and um yeah so in order to
get they considered Paul Bernardo more
dangerous because he started out before
he met her he was the quote-unquote
Scarborough rapist
um and he raped like a bunch of women
and then they got together and then like
all kind of horrible [__] ensued
so um including them killing her sister
like hit like her yeah essentially
remember like because he he was mad
because Carla wasn't a virgin like they
got married like the two of them were
married he was mad that Carla wasn't a
virgin so Carla was like oh well I'll
give you my 15 year old yeah sister like
he raped and killed her yeah they didn't
mean to kill her
exactly but she died and then they but
then later they did absolutely mean to
kill the people yeah but yeah so how
does how is it they didn't mean to kill
her how do we know that
um well what happened was she was she
worked at um Carla Homolka she worked at
a Veterinary Clinic she was like a
veterinary assistant and so she would
take drugs from there okay and so she
drugged her sister because she wanted
her sister to be unconscious like
because that was his thing like a date
rape thing right and so and she I guess
didn't know and she like gave her too
much yeah overdosed her because they
called 9-1-1 and everything like that so
then because they panicked right but um
so there's a record of it but they just
thought it was an accident at first but
uh yeah but then they went on to
actually like kill people later but
that's
but the thing about it was that that's
weird so the first one well because yeah
I mean well the authorities
I guess they wanted Paul Bernardo and
they didn't have at first they didn't
have I think like the DNA like they had
DNA from the crime scenes and they did
actually eventually match it up but it
took like I mean the cops in this case
were like really I have to say we're
just really drop the ball like on
numerous occasions when they could have
like got this [__] off the
street and they just didn't do it
but
um so when when they first knew that it
was him she kind of rolled like Carla
kind of rolled over on him and so they
needed her testimony like to put him in
prison because they like I said
considered that him to be like I'm a lot
more dangerous than her because at first
they thought she was also a victim you
know what I mean guess what it's 8 30.
yeah I know what time do we we have to
leave around nine don't we nine nine
thirty something like that because you
have to get ready first right you were
mostly ready right all I have to do is
put shoes on and get my phone so we're
gonna leave around 9 30. okay yeah yeah
uh somebody sent us some money thank you
Zach by the way good news Danny
Masterson went to prison so it looks
like the first real nail in Scientology
yeah I forgot I know the name Masterson
which one was that he was that actor
right didn't you did he rape somebody
right
I thought
I thought that was the that was I don't
know how hot how high up in the church
he is I mean that shirt well he was one
of the better known like celebrities
okay that that doesn't mean anything
because those guys have gone to prison
many times that won't topple the church
the church is already kind of collapsed
it can't really
get guilty of two counts of rape yeah
yeah if I can uh that church isn't going
anywhere everybody that was going to
leave already left
only the hardcore people yeah
Scientology will just
slowly shrink as the members die away
but it will probably always be there
strangely enough
that might live on for about another 70
years
but they'll probably slow slowly sell
off property
I mean I just like I said find it hard
to believe that anybody would still but
you know it's I I know that people that
are stuck in there like that were maybe
born in there they don't know any better
but
the the test will be what happens when
David miscavige dies
if miscavage Dies who takes this place
and Tom Cruise it probably would
yeah I wasn't even joking not joking
probably would be Tom Cruise Tyler said
if they ever lose Tom Cruise they're
[__]
that might be a good thing though you
know if miscavige dies and Cruz takes
over
Crews might actually take that church
into him into a more rational place I
don't know he'd probably run it the way
Miss cabbage runs it for a while
but then he he might he might change
some things which might buy that church
more time
there's no no Talent
but yeah
Tom Cruise would probably take over
didn't that weird he probably never
[__] crossed my mind yeah that he
would but he has the most pull on the
most clout really in order to take over
Scientology you need popularity
that's how Miss cabbage got it
and then once he was installed there was
no way to get him out
if he was gone Miss cabbage
Tom Cruise would probably take over or
Marty or Marty Marty Rathbone I can't
see that happen he's he's excommunicated
they'll probably ever do it but uh
holy [__] like all of the all of the
[__] scientologists would [__]
cream themselves if Tom Cruise yeah [__]
over they love him they love him and
that's probably who would take over all
of the people you know in when I lived
in Clearwater and worked for those
[__] weirdos over there
um man they just every time they talked
about Tom Cruise they were just like
they were like Tom Cruise because some
of them had met him you know because he
would come to like all the Scientology
[__] like meetings or whatever like
in Clearwater and so some of the people
that worked there had met him and they
were just like talked about him like he
was [__] God on Earth and I'm oh I'm
open uh about my uh gayness
he's gay for Tom Cruise no I I'm just
what what I like to say is that uh I
respect Tom Cruise you're cheating on
Tom Hardy cheating on time yeah yeah
cheating on Tom Hardy with Tom Cruise
Tom Ross is cheating on Tom Cruise with
Trump or Tom Hardy it's the three times
the three times oh my God you guys
should have a Thomas it's the Holy
Trinity
I'm all short too I watch that well I
don't know if Tom Cruise wasn't involved
yeah they're all I'd watch porn of you
and Tom Hardy though
Mom and Tom Zach would you watch that me
and Tom Hardy's Dad could watch that I
couldn't I can't arrange it though dude
call him up and just call him he might
be dead I'm trying to call him Tom
Cruise
I'd be less enthusiastic about that but
you know what I mean
um
but no I respect Tom Cruise's uh [__]
dedication to to the art of acting to
the theater he's actually a good movie
star real good and he's done he's done a
lot in terms of [__] you know action
skills and he's come through and the
mother look man
say what you will about Tom Cruise
he could deliver
he he he he gives it his all in every
[__] movie and that last uh Top Gun
movie Top Gun Maverick I saw it I
enjoyed it to me it was a standard movie
that's the way movies just should be
that's the way they were when I was
growing up a lot of people were
impressed because how
traditional it was I understand it yeah
it was good it was just a retelling of
Star Wars in many ways destroying the
Death Star
uh
but man that [__] made all the money
it did yeah made all the money so yeah
I'm able to say yeah Tom you [__]
knocked the [__] out now I want to see
another [__] um Mission Impossible
because I like all the Mission
Impossible movies to [__] the Ethan
Hunt character I'm all about it
uh now when it comes to Tom
on a personal level I like Tom on a
personal level actually I think I think
Scientology did help him
um I don't believe in Scientology
but I think they helped him uh
well he'd be the only person that they
helped other than the people at the top
that make all the money yeah he he had
a very customized unique experience of
[__] Scientology just because it
helped Tom Cruise they had to help Tom
Cruise okay they wanted to use him
um and he gained a lot of power in the
church and by all accounts he loves that
he loves Scientology
or he did at least
um
people that have seen him in the
scientological [__]
uh world and the way he operates
evidently he's diabolical uh what
happened did you that yeah sorry I keep
looking down because like I had a ring
on and it of course got caught on my
stockings and I can't get it off I get
it and I don't want to tear these
because I just got them because normally
if it was like an old pair I'd just go I
would just I see what it did it's goth
problems yeah every single thing you
wear like catches on every single other
thing caught around the little snake's
head yeah I know
Zach says uh I don't need to watch porn
of Tom Hardy that is I've already seen
Tom Hardy's ass when he posts nudes to
Myspace back in the day when he was on
all the drugs he said his ass is
glorious
I bet it is Tom Hardy was posting his
ass that's awesome well Myspace that was
a long time ago that was a long time ago
a lot of it you got it part of it
yeah
and then Tammy points out and you can
see all of Tom Hardy and Bronson that's
right yeah that's right
Mr 88 says Tom Cruise is an elite level
professional just do not like him as a
guy yeah same
I'm not you know we talk about this all
the time you know I feel like we're
always like talking about [__] Tom
Cruise not probably not as much as we
talk about Steven Seagal but I do
Sarah said Scientology groomed the hell
out of Tom Cruise oh yeah yeah yeah
absolutely yeah
I'm gonna have to break it yeah I guess
just cut it off dude because it won't
make much difference because you it has
holes in it anyway that's okay I see
what it did it just looked this is all
it did is it removed that one okay
nobody will notice there's a lot of that
on there I have another pair like this
anyway no there's a lot of it it matches
the theme okay the whole theme is ripped
it's the ripped thing ripped to the
maximum
Taylor the guys the Tyler the guy sorry
uh Tom Hardy played the villain in a
Star Trek movie and he was high out of
his mind the entire time
which Star Trek oh yeah the um
yeah I saw that movie that's right which
one was it I didn't realize that was him
but I know exactly yeah he played the
Romulan guy oh yeah that's right I think
I forgot all about that
yeah I do eyeballs huh well
I mean in a way I find that like even
more admirable because
you know showing up at work and like
doing some [__] like that and you're
just completely high as balls and it's
still like passable like to get on you
yeah but he didn't have to say much
that's true but still yeah
DJ Maniac said so was Van Damme in
Street Fighter lots of cocaine yeah
yeah and Dan was a [__] Coke freak
I haven't seen Street Fighter in a very
very long time
I had the [__] I had the universal
Soldier too the second one it's not two
it's just something called something
else
and there's there's a bunch of Universal
Soldiers movies they all [__] suck
and I had the second one it has yeah
it's terrible
that's [__] terrible the first one
wasn't that great I like the first one
the first one the first one had a
certain charm to it okay yeah the format
that it that it was in it just it was in
that 80s format uh that didn't translate
well to the to the modern screen they
put that CGI in it and everything and
it's just it's
a little too much real they tried to get
too much realism in it but it was the it
was the it was the Steven Seagal realism
you know what I mean of like a bad
Steven Seagal movie that's what that's
what it's like
just the tone I'm like man this is this
is terrible
well Zach said I just sent Tom one of
the pictures oh did you have Tom Hardy's
ass let me go see let's see let's see
Tom Hardy's ass you can't you can't put
it on the show
yeah he's like I need glasses I need
glasses I'm gonna [__] analyze this
[__]
it's an ass analysis I'm gonna [__]
like try to pick a switch here so I
could perceive this from the eyes of gay
man
straight man trying to see it through
the eyes he's switching into gay eyes
yeah switching to chaos
right
okay yeah all right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
damn he's got the back arch and
everything goodness Jump On In yeah yeah
yeah and he's touching himself on the
mirror okay I understand your fixation
Zach okay okay let me go switch my
[__] straight eyes back
you giving me this [__]
no it's not love
yeah he was uh committed to to that
curve yeah the little might have the
booty [__] um send you over there so
he can give you some lessons I want that
back arch just like that
the game I have lower background look
like a damn slinky
uh I'd have to practice that we'll see
there there you go there you go
Tyler the guy said analyzing Tom Hardy's
ass like Indiana Jones analyzing a
thousand-year-old artifact
s
and where he's got the got the weight in
the bag and he's going
it's like that but with a butt but with
the ass
hahaha
and the wall is falling
they're like the rock star rolling down
the [__] [__] Spike's coming down and
why not didn't work
didn't work
it's not intact
let me go get another drink yeah yeah
how much time we have um a while it's
quarter to nine I can't
well I can oh yeah
[Laughter]
I mean I don't want to get super [__]
up but it does actually work out like if
I drink before we go because then by the
time we get there I'm just kind of like
I don't really want any more drinks like
maybe I'll have like one more and then
because the parts It'll like the
bartender there Heather she knows my
deal and she knows that we do like if we
come on Friday night she knows that we
do this show beforehand and that we
drink on that so it's like she'll do
like one drink and then like a big thing
of water and then she's like you want
another drink or just water so she keeps
like giving me water like all night
because she knows she knows how I do
John Gore says no homo but Steve Reeves
was one handsome mofo just watch one of
his Hercules movies uh he was yeah he
was yeah
um
it's like it's Friday enjoy these
cocktails yeah there's actually like
kind of a shorter week which was nice
because I had Monday off but
it still took forever holy crap you guys
this week was it Wednesday no
what [__] day
I guess it was yesterday
or the day before I can't remember if it
was Wednesday or Thursday because it's
all blurring together
but
I was at work and it's like in case you
don't know like I we live in Eustis
which is like in Central Florida and I
work in South Daytona which is over on
the coast so it's about an hour drive
it's about 54 miles like one way
so I'm at work on either Wednesday or
Thursday afternoon and I had just gotten
back from lunch I take lunch from one to
two
and somebody like the lady who works in
the front she comes in and she's like oh
there's cops out in the parking lot
and they have their guns drawn and
everything and they told us everybody
stay in the building and lock all the
doors
because they were like after somebody
and we were like oh great it's like the
middle of the afternoon right
so we're like holy [__] so we just like
stand and the power had gone out too but
it came back on like a few seconds later
and so we were like kind of true it
wasn't like a lockdown or anything like
that but we're in there and it's like we
kept looking out and it's like there's
cops all out in the parking lot and
they're just like you guys aren't really
aren't allowed to come out like keep all
the doors locked and everything like
that and then like the SWAT team came
and there was like helicopters and
everything I'm like what the [__] and I
was like and I was texting like Tom the
whole time like what was going on
because I couldn't really see because
I'm like way in the back but I was just
kind of like yeah there's like cops and
SWAT team and helicopters and [__]
outside and I was like Stay classy
Daytona because you know what I mean
it's kind of it's maybe uncharitable I
drew I was born there okay and I grew up
there for like many many years so I'm
allowed to say it's kind of a trashy
place it's kind of trashy so uh so yeah
so there's all this kind of [__] going
on and then finally like that goes on
for a couple hours and I'm just like man
they better have this [__] resolved like
by the time I leave somebody really
pissed if I have to like stay here late
you know uh and they won't let me leave
because there's like a [__] fugitive
on the loose or something like that but
thankfully by the time I left work you
know it had all been resolved but I
found out the next day
what had happened
what happened was
right up the street like I had just come
back from lunch so it was like two
o'clock in the afternoon
and
thank you
and apparently right up the street from
my work
somebody like a dude in a car had pulled
up at a red light next to another dude
in the car and just opened fire at the
car they were fighting killed the driver
there was I think it was a passenger in
the car too but I don't know if the
passenger was killed I think they were
just wounded
and then the person that had shot the
other person like kind of tried to take
off and they were right in the vicinity
of like work because where I work it's
like in this little like industrial park
that's kind of like behind like some
other [__] it's like it's sort of off
the road and they thought he went in
there they did catch him later on
but for a while they thought maybe he
was hiding out somewhere like around and
I was like he better not be hiding out
my [__] back seat you know what I
mean because I told him that holy [__]
and I was just like read what Victor
said where
uh this guy in Daytona broke into a
house because he said he was being
chased by a ghost yeah yeah that doesn't
surprise me
yeah Daytona yeah Florida man yeah yeah
man I mean it's a meme for a reason it's
a meme for a reason Florida man a lot of
drugs here
yeah I mean it's it's drugs it's General
stupidity low income drugs
hot weather
yeah guys from all over the [__]
South coming here to party some of them
from the north to [__] party they end
up the homeless I mean everyone's kind
of rednecky and I don't know not
everyone not everyone but like Daytona
is like Daytona is largely redneck and
like I said I was I was born there and I
lived there for like a really long time
so it's like so I could say that yeah
Daytona's red decks yeah but so so that
was scary and then like I told him so I
was texting him like the whole time and
I'm just like yeah the [__] SWAT
team's outside and all this other kind
of crap I said this dude better not be
hiding out my [__] back seat when I
go out there to leave or whatever it's
just like from a [__] urban legend
and then I told him I said oh and by the
way this morning when I was driving to
work I was on 92 like right outside of
Daytona us 92 and I had stopped like the
the Votran which is the County bus it
had stopped to pick somebody up and then
so like the bus was stopped the SUV had
stopped and then I stopped behind the
SUV and I was just like hanging out and
then I looked and glanced in my rearview
mirror and this dude was flying up
behind me he he had to be in going like
90 miles an hour and I guess he didn't
realize that the traffic had stopped
right and so like all literally all I
had the time to do was like I glanced in
my mirror and I was like
and I just went like that because I was
like holy [__] he's gonna hit me because
he was right there yeah and then so like
and then all of a sudden the car just
went like swept around me and my car
went like that and I was like
from the wake of this yeah I was like
what the [__] any um and there was a car
in the next Lane too so he almost hit
that [__]
and I was like holy [__] he but he could
have just like [__] creamed me
because I would have bet I would have
been went right into that back of that
SUV and right into the back of that bus
yeah because we were stopped that ain't
[__] man me and Jenny were one time
coming back from uh downtown Orlando we
were both [__] three sheets to the
wind
coming back from um
independent bar
Eye bar
and uh we're going on was it I-75 I-75
what's the name of it I-45 I-4 I-4
excuse me
Ben Jacob
going down I-4
and all of a sudden we were in the
middle of a [__] cut like a 12 car
pileup
yeah just all the cars around us all
started Wrecking
and um well actually I pulled up on it I
was like what is this and then more cars
started wrecking behind us and [__] they
were like uh what the [__] and a dude a
truck it was like a Ford F-250
passed right next to me went into a
fishtail type Spin and and and then came
to a [__] rest backwards facing me
remember that dude and [__] he's
sitting there like damn after it
happened and as I'm looking at him
another car coming to hits him and kills
him pow just [__] obliterates the car
remember that
vaguely vaguely remember that yeah I was
looking right at him that car hit him
and just killed him the no man could be
accelerated that that quickly
and survive it
and I look behind me and there's [__]
more lights
of cars piling up and I said [__] it I
went around the car in front of me and
we and and then just weaved my way
through all those wrecks and then left
trying to hold it and I can see it
headlights do this
turn it like okay it's like a headlights
should be pointing this way just go on
which meant that they were all back
there wrecking yeah
so even drunk I can make a good decision
I'm like nope we're not staying here man
these cars we've had some close calls
man yeah do you remember one night we
were coming back from ibar and I
remember this because it was it was
right around Halloween it might have
been the Halloween party and we had Toby
was in the back seat because we were dry
we were dropping him off at his house
because it was on the way
and we were on the on-ramp but you know
the traffic was kind of backed up and so
you know we stopped obviously and the
person behind us obviously didn't look
where they were going and did not stop
and they rammed into the back of my car
yeah and knocked off the back bumper
yeah and then went and then they went
Wham and I was like what the [__] and
then they just went and they took off
and then they took off and I was like
well because he was drunk yeah and then
like when we got to Toby's house
that him and Toby got out of the car and
they said well Johnny I hate to tell you
this but your back bumper is gone yeah
it is a new one it just completely
followed it so like the guy just like
hit us and left and I was like well
that's fantastic yeah
oh my God
[Music]
these dude said maybe you shouldn't stop
on the freeway there's no choice
well where I was I mean [__] piled up
yeah I mean yeah it was a huge wreck and
the thing too I don't know if you were
talking about like when I was um
like what happened just a couple days
ago it's not a freeway yeah it's a you
know it's just like U.S highways but you
know what I mean there's stops what they
call an interstate
well I don't even know if it's that it's
just just a highway yeah yeah it's just
a two-lane highway it's old it's like
one of the old highways and like I said
there's bus stops all along here so the
bus stops like you can't and really
technically the uh speed limit's 55 even
though everybody goes 70 80. yeah
including me yeah admit but but you're
only supposed to go fishing on the
freeway the
speed limit is 70 miles an hour
that'll be nothing man most people are
going about 90. it's almost like the
Autobahn here and in that yeah people
travel extreme like crazy going 90
there's cops in it
well [__] I had that happen one time I
was gonna I was going down 92 and there
wasn't any traffic and if there's no
traffic like sometimes I'll be going
super fast without realizing and so I'm
just like cruising down 92 on the way
home and I think I was going to like 95
or something like that yeah and then I'm
like just sing around my music and then
all of a sudden like this cop is like
right next to me and I'm just like oh
[__] yeah and then I was like they
really don't I'm just gonna like pretend
I'm not that I don't see him I'm just
gonna act yeah now I've had nothing but
good experience with Florida cops they
only care about crime
they're not real worried about [__]
well it's not like I mean if you are in
heavy traffic and you're weaving around
like an [__] they'll get you yeah
they're gonna and you're going really
fast yeah they'll pull you over them but
like really if there's nobody else
around and you're not really endangering
anyone yeah then and you're not going
like excessively fast then they'll
probably leave you alone you don't seem
to care about weed I've seen
dudes smoking out in public they just
don't seem to care
um
in the 80s and 90s it was common
especially down in the Miami area to
just snort cocaine on the [__]
tables of the not of the of certain
nightclubs they just did that openly
because they just owned the place the
freaking go take cartels over the place
go see go see uh there's a Netflix
series called Cocaine Cowboys
it was recommended us I think designated
recommended it's a [__] great series
and that that's like
80s
Miami and it's portrayed as being well
that was back then
but I've heard it's still like that
they lock up a damn
cocaine drug lord
and then they'd he'd lock him up for
like 10 15 years but as soon as they
locked him up like a man a [__] month
later he gets arrested for driving a car
like are you supposed to be in prison
oh yeah about that yeah
I thought you were supposed to be a
president
[Laughter]
whoever was running the prison let him
out
all right
so things don't really work
as advertised in places where there's a
lot of money
with crime going on
and uh you've even heard like the mayor
down there who's he's supposed to be
pretty good in front of his name I think
his name is Castro no not Castro Santos
or something remember that guy's name
the mayor of that I remember
I've seen interviews with him
he's about
growing Miami and making money he
doesn't want people shooting he's told
him he says I don't really care what you
do just don't shoot the place up [__]
it's got to be a great place for all of
us to live and and for the most part
that's what's happening there are car
drug cartels down there but they're not
causing any trouble in their in general
and they're not at least the mid and the
high ranking guys aren't
and they're not in the con conflict with
the police
most of the stuff that's happening down
there is real low level just Street dogs
they're doing [__] but the guys that
have all the money they're not doing
anything
and um
you see like it's a bad reflection on
Florida
[Music]
South Florida is like another country
it's more like Central America
uh just in in about every way it's not
like Central Florida or Northern Florida
and those people that live there have
been there for centuries and that's
that's how they do things
in general they're peaceful and [__]
that whole [__]
that whole Miami Skyline was built on
cocaine money
there was that wasn't there until
cocaine
Tyler the guy said have you guys ever
heard of Jeremy DeWitt he's a crazy
[__] down there in Florida he keeps
getting in trouble for pretending to be
a cop oh no I don't that name yeah that
does sound familiar doesn't it yeah they
have cereal cop impersonators dudes some
of them are like rapists and stuff too
and actually there was one that was a
serial killer I can't remember what his
name was I think the one he's talking
about is the guy that goes out there and
directs traffic
yeah maybe yeah I think he just that
would be real that would be weird yeah I
mean I mean at least it's relatively
on the list but it's better than like
going and raping and murdering people
that's for sure but what a weird thing
if you're gonna like pretend to be a cop
it's like well I want to pretend to be a
cop but only so I can go direct traffic
well he wants people to see him as a cop
look at me I'm a cop I'm sexy
here's my cop car
stripper yeah
he wants to be seen as a real cop
if that's if it's the same guy
Tyler said yeah that's the guy that's
the guy okay he also speeds through
traffic on a motorcycle yeah yeah that's
another thing he's a fake cop but he's
just directed traffic and putting out
[__] flares and cones and
which is kind of cute when you think
about it but it's like he's got a
problem he's got a mental problem
obviously yeah obviously he wants to be
respected
well why doesn't he do something that's
like worthy of respect then why does he
just become a cop but he you can't I
guess I guess you know
but he he wants people to see him as a
cop he's it's like cop LARPing yeah yeah
but he's getting psychological
gratification I'm telling people to go
I'm helping the community you know I'm
helping the community I'm helping them
go get around these flares that I put
there yeah
put the flares out put out the cones
close the roads and [__] yeah
that's pretty funny I've seen videos of
the cops arresting him
and he tries to talk his way out of the
arrest no man no like he tries to pass
himself off as a real cop it doesn't hit
you it doesn't work
John Gore said actual cops probably
tolerated to an extent they're like hey
if he wants to do these lamb chops yeah
no they get him he's got fake cop cars
and everything they fake cop motorcycle
yeah which is easy to do you can buy the
cars you can buy the car they're doing
and it's just the tape work you can you
can do it it's not difficult well yeah
everything that they're wearing you can
buy openly in the U.S market from police
supply police military supply stores a
lot of it's online you just got to know
what it is that they buy
and of course you know the guns you can
buy those here
anything that a cop has pretty much a
civilian can get
machine guns you can get them too you
just have to go through class three
it'll be a class three manufacturing you
can get them and that that license isn't
that hard to get it's just a federal
background check I think it's 200 a year
and then you can purchase and possess
machine guns you can't transfer them
until unless somebody else
is has some kind of class 3 license Dave
is in the chat hello YouTube had a long
day but going tonight yeah we're going
to yeah we're going we'll be up there we
have I feel like we haven't been to
mannequins in a while
for like a month or two right yeah Tyler
said that's the thing he was training to
be a cop in his 20s but it fell through
after he got in trouble for sleeping
with a teenager okay so yeah he's never
gonna get on there
probably he's losing a state of
something that you should be doing he
lives in a state of [__] Perpetual
guilt and regret
so he was trying to live out his [__]
cop fantasy
yeah that's [__] weird is he guilty
or regretful about it though I wonder
probably is he just mad that he got
caught oh no yeah Matt yeah those are
[__] those are two different things he
does not want his [__] he does not
want his
fantasy his dream of being a cop impeded
see see he's going to be a cop on his
own time and he's just gonna drink
he says he you don't even have to I
wonder if he still sleeps with teenagers
too because he's like no one's gonna
tell me what to do you're not the boss
of me
but he sounds like he may not be a
totally stable type personality yeah you
think yeah yeah Sebastian Moran said one
day he may become a Maniac Cop yeah
that's a movie that we haven't covered
that may haven't done the Maniac Cop
movies yeah maybe you should do those I
think shutter had him I don't know if
they still have him I haven't seen him
oh they're good you probably really dig
them actually
I mean at least I remember the first one
being good I don't remember the other
one so much I want to see the
Exterminator I've never seen it oh yeah
evidently that that was actually what
inspired the Terminator
the Terminator was a rip-off
of a [__] B movie called The
Exterminator yeah I thought it was the
other way around because I saw the
exterminator in the video store since
the eyes of Terminator rip off
no Terminator was a ripoff of that
isn't that weird see just like how
everybody thought that Hydrox cookies
were a ripoff of Oreo but actually it
was the other way around yeah Hydrox
came first they were the originals and
Oreo ripped them off yeah
fun fact Hydrox is not as good though
yeah I'll concede that but I'm just
saying they were the first ones to do
that they had a white cookie though that
was pretty good and they have one that
has a Hydrox that has a chocolate cookie
and a vanilla cookie with the on the
same cookie you seen that one yeah yeah
the little half breeds I guess what
would you call them
and they have the [__] cream filling
they're good man
I mean I tend to prefer
like the vanilla cookies anyway rather
yeah yeah I mean the thing is if I'm
gonna eat Oreos yeah I either want
double stuffs because I don't really
like that chocolate cookie so it needs
all of that cream to balance out yeah or
I like the ones that have that are like
dipped in something like they have like
the Oreo that's like a double stuff that
it's like dipped in white chocolate that
shit's good you can take Oreos and crush
them in the bottom of a pie pan and it
becomes a pie crust
the [__] cream in it and everything
just leave it in there
and you might want to make it pretty
good pour some melted butter on it brush
it on and then just uh
continue just put your pie filling in it
that's good works it works
Zach says why would you name your sweet
product he's talking about Hydrox to
sound like a cleaning product or
antipsychotic drug see that's what I
always do you're old that was a long
time that was like old times they didn't
know how to name ship it yeah they gave
stuff all kinds well they probably
thought that was a really cool name back
then it sounded futuristic one of the
oldest [__] candies that we we you
can still have them you can order them
from vintage places where [__] Neko
Wafers yeah and they almost tasted like
medicine
they were a little [__] tablets
covered in like a waxy powder in a
[__] wax paper roll
and they were different colors but I
didn't really notice any different
flavors except the licorice ones I could
taste those I think the chocolate one
was kind of chocolate is licorice
chocolate
I guess strawberry it was red and then a
white one and they had some green ones
I'm devious and a yellow one I think
maybe there was a yellow one in there
stacked in there but you can get a whole
thing of them for like when I was a kid
like five sets
but if your friends saw you eating those
like oh you better have any money you
don't have any money because you really
should have got a Jolly Rancher you know
that's what I mean you got five whole
cents and you're spending it on that
[__] well no you needed more you
needed like 10 for a Jolly Rancher stick
I think it was 10th well Jolly Rancher
but for five you could get a [__]
necklace they're like making fun of you
for making fun of you always have no you
only had five you couldn't get the good
you couldn't get the good [__]
got that from the Mexican store not in
California down in Long Beach and Carson
actually I mean if you're gonna have
candy have some [__] candy man it's
like a way that's like barely not that's
not even food right to be honest with
you like much less candy
a little that was [__]
um
when I was living in California as a
little kid
uh went to Dominguez Elementary
with uh Quentin Tarantino but we figured
it out I remembered him but he was a
little bit older than me I thought he
was in my class but I think he was like
two or three years older man I remember
him though
and he worked at the video store
down the street Dominguez
I lived on [__] 25 24
.
Jackson Street that's what it was in
Dominguez 25 23 little bitty house tiny
all right we went up the [__] Street
turn the corn and turned the other
Corner we have what me and other little
kids call the Mexican store
and it was a dive store
and uh
I don't even think Mexicans owned it but
we just called it the Mexican store
because they had a bunch of Mexican
products in it and uh
so we call it the Mexican story did they
have the stoplight candy they had all
kinds of cool candy and I was talking to
kind of Aslan about it says remember
that remember the candy look like a damn
umbrella it was green white and red the
colors of the Mexican flag it looked
like a number it was a sucker it looked
like an umbrella and and he showed me
pictures of this one and I said yeah
that one because man I forgot all about
that he forgot about them too
all right and then they had little
Mexican candies that were uh
uh one of them was just a wax paper with
little round dots on it yeah those
they were cinnamon flavored I think yeah
well they we had those too yeah those
two okay yeah yeah and then uh then it
had a bunch of [__] like salted prunes
that came in a bag that was the Mexican
thing hey keep your regular yeah even
for kids they were so [__] salty and
then little dried Gulf Shrimp with
[__] Mexican seasoning on them all
right I could get I could get on board
yeah you were totally dried and they
still had the shell on them though
they'll just crunch them like [__] them
candy yeah well not quite like candy but
well like little you know they were
totally dry totally dry they were just
totally dehydrated so they they would
last forever and they would come in a
little vacuum packed [__] plastic bag
with a [__]
that sounds like some [__] that we would
get for Pokey yeah like something you
give her poop exactly
because we got her that one time because
we got her like this little bag of like
little bitty dried fishies yeah that was
the Mexican stuff they have the heads
and everything yeah and she like
crunches them up like with the bones
there's a bunch of other little Mexican
candies we would get but I forgot what
they were I remember them when I was
talking about talking to [__] Khan
it was just like
a little Mexican candies
things made out of [__] coconut and
[__]
we're not wrong with that I love you
yeah it was that was good yeah it was
good we liked Mexican candy real sugary
and then they'd have [__] sweet and
spicy mixed together
or and then there was a lot of stuff in
Brazil you called salgado's things that
are salty they're not sweet they're
salty like the little shrimp things
every time and uh
salted prunes they came in a bag that's
crazy I remember those [__] like
yesterday I could remember I could taste
them just talking about them it's how
[__] strong they were
um that's funny that like I just
imagined like all these little boys
going in there and being like let's try
these salted prunes yeah yeah well we
buy them that's fine yeah because that's
usually that's not something like me and
my siblings would have bought
from the Mexican store
and then in the back in the cooler they
had all kinds of [__] soda but we we
bought White Rock soda they had a little
[__] pixie drinking out of the
[__] head oh yeah I remember that
yeah White Rock
it's because it was cheaper yeah yeah
but it was good real good
the drink like creams White Rock cream
soda White Rock like lemon lime and
I think there was a cola
and it came in a glass bottle
with a pretty girl look we thought it
was [__] we we thought it was [__]
uh Tinkerbell
drinking out it does kind of look like
drinking out of the water yeah yeah I
remember that I don't remember she had
wings though did she
yeah I thought she had wings but I don't
but maybe I could I don't know it's been
a long time since did she have boobies
she was very slander I don't think she
had boobs it's just like a it was like a
silhouette okay I gotcha she's very real
little and skinny and from this is just
memory I think she did have like little
dragonfly wings coming out of the
background out of her back
yeah that's how I remember this sitting
on a rock
bent forward drinking out of the water I
think you could see like a little
[__] ring of [__] ripples where
she was drinking like a kitty cat yeah
yeah we liked it we were like oh is she
pretty you know look he has a little
pretty cartoon yeah yeah we were like
it's Tinkerbell
you could Tinkerbell throw it up
Tinkerbell
Zach says at least it sounds better than
that cherry flavored liquid cold
medicine I took when I was a kid that
[__] was so nasty it always almost made
me want to puke oh man we drink that
[__] I wonder if that was I wonder if
that was like pre-emulsion because I
used to drink that
yeah that's probably what's wrong with
me today I thought it was good craziest
thing I did was I was looking that's not
the craziest thing I didn't laugh yeah I
was gonna say there's a lot there's a
lot of competition I was like five or
six and I was
went up to my dad's Dressing Table this
is this is on [__] over on Jackson
Street
and I was looking at all the [__] his
colognes and aftershaves and he had some
aqua valve up there's green
they had a liquor cabinet too in the
house that I used to drink from
because of course you did yeah it's the
70s you know little kids could drink in
the 70s do that but if you you could
drink
they would they would laugh if you were
drinking they're like look at that kid
yeah I can't tell you drinking stories
but uh so I look at the [__] Aqua
valve and I'm smelling so that smells
pretty good as I start taking a drink
chug it Tom I said okay so I chugged the
[__]
I was [__] loaded on the aqua Vellum
you smell like what is that you know
assistant
she can smell it on me and she's like
where is it because I drank it she took
me to the emergency room
yeah I was probably about three I think
three or four
I could talk but I was little
and uh they took the emergency room he
drank the whole thing Aqua velve with
the doctor went he drank that velvet
isn't it I was like yeah
he's doing this in his track he's he's
doing this for my eyes and he said look
at my finger and he goes yeah kid's
loaded
I just take him home and sleep it off
[Laughter]
stop it he's like no no no no no no no
no no
he died yeah just alcohol
was that the time was that the time that
they asked you about
um
what was the thing with the turtles
turtles yeah yeah I had this okay
because that was the funniest part of
the story for me
I was still small enough to wear a
[__]
I eat with a bib
yeah so yeah you're little yeah yeah
and
nowadays it would just be a bib but back
in the 70s it was a a bib was just a
napkin okay paper nap
but to hold it around your neck they had
a string and instead of having like two
clips like clothespins
they were like clothespins but they were
shaped like turtles pink Turtles
well I used to carry those things around
not all when I was a kid when I was
little
well when they took me to the hospital I
grabbed them on the way out
I'm taking my friends with me yes I'm
[__] sitting there playing with the
[__] turtles
in the emergency room right
and uh
[Laughter]
so part of the test they're doing the
doing my finger tracking and [__] like
that and [__] daughter says what is
that it is pointing at it and I'm like
what my mom my mom goes he's asking what
kind of animal is that and I go
kitty cat
and I started laughing kitty cat
I knew it was Turtles
and it's like that was why the doctor
said yeah he's loaded
I love that that's so [__] funny I
can imagine it's going kitty cat
[Laughter]
that guy was four
Tyler says even as a kid Tom was a
certified Florida man yeah yeah yeah I
grew up like that yeah
I mean there's all kind of like crazy
drinking stories from you from you were
a little kid yeah and I'm not an
alcoholic no okay it's just in the 70s
our parents were young they were in
their 20s and they had booze all over
the house and me and my other friends
and Jimmy and Mike live up the street
we'd raid the booze [__] we'd be
raised the book we raised raid the booze
my mom bought a thing with my dad my dad
bought
a one gallon
of wine by Annie Green Springs wine
it was cheap wine they were mixing it
with seven up
there's a big thing in California about
50 50. and the girls were drinking it
yeah because they have wine coolers back
then that's where the wine cooler came
from yeah okay yeah that was a
California thing they were making them
themselves
especially up in the [__] like they
were going up to Seattle Sierra Nevada
mountains to go camping and up to
Sequoia they'd buy a [__] a whole
bunch of [__]
seven up and those Annie Green Spring
Wine jugs they were [__] a gallon
glass jug
with a hole with like a a ring on the
[__] neck where you could hold it
like a [__]
old moonshine job but it was clear
glass
Jimmy micro at my house we saw that
[__] jug of wine
and I remember Mike he was a little bit
older than us
he was probably about seven at the time
I was probably about five
guys Mike goes that's why
he starts opening up he starts drinking
so it looks good and I said give me some
so we start drinking the [__] wine we
got loaded
[Laughter]
and [__] Michael's let's go outside
we go outside with The Jug and we're out
there in the front yard [__] doing
like it's only five six seven year olds
yeah like that sitting on the front cars
cars are driving by seeing us out in the
[__] yard passing The Jug around dude
people dudes are laughing
talking horse
one lady says where's your mama she see
the word
she's at work she says what are you
doing it's a drink of wine
what does it look like [__] the whole
all the neighbors came out you know
[__] Mrs Brooke I think it was Mrs
Brewers
the old lady lived next door she took
the wine bottle from it
I told on but it didn't matter they just
laughed our parents was like you were
out there drinking water yeah they were
standing out in the middle of the
[__] yard in front of traffic passing
the wine yeah chugging it
I mean that is pretty funny it's funny
yeah
you turned out all right mostly oh yeah
we were Pharaoh children
yeah basically California kids were
caught in almost as much trouble as
Mississippi kids we used to go down in
California down to the [__] flood
control system
Los Angeles River that's where they
filled them we'd go down there and try
to make steal gasoline and make [__]
torches and go down inside the [__]
flood control tunnels looking for the
giant looking for the giant ants and
[__] he's scared you know no no keep
going keep going no no no no that was
also where the [__] baby from from
it's alive that's right yeah all that
was in there we were scared of death of
that place but we good at but it was it
had marshes around it and Wildlife
preserves
and shallow like three foot deep water
we jump in it
we were trying to catch [__] crawfish
we got like three crawfish they were
that big a little bit we tried to cook
them and eat them they were tasted
terrible it's all you know just [__]
kids to do you know
probably about time for us to leave huh
yeah I was gonna say it's getting to be
about that yeah yeah it's about that
time I wanted to go to the restroom all
right y'all I'll be I'll see y'all uh
next week well Sunday Sunday yeah all
right so thanks everybody for dropping
by this evening we gotta go because
we're going out in a little bit
I have to put shoes on and whatnot and
finding what I'm doing so yeah we'll be
back on Sunday I'm pretty sure we're
going to be talking about snatch because
xanadas sent us that and we're gonna
watch that this weekend and then we're
gonna talk about that on Sunday so
that's another um you know that's kind
of like the second one after a Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels the guy
Richie movie so we're gonna be talking
about that on Sunday so hopefully you
guys have a good rest of your evening
and have a good day tomorrow and we'll
see you guys again on Sunday good night